the phone was propped up in the bedroom
and the pictures were live streamed into
the world it seems the owner knew a
South African woman in an abusive
relationship
films herself being attacked by a man
who is unable to restrain himself the
phone belongs to one of the biggest
stars on the South African music scene
called babes Widow MO and she hasn't
made a public appearance since the
attack the alleged perpetrator is
well-known in fact he appears in this
video he's known as musician man pincher
MS widow Mose music producer after a
public outcry man pincher was charged
with a common assault in a Durban
courtroom but after the hearing
he said his girlfriend was responsible
for the beating charged domestic
violence is endemic in South Africa but
this attack has hit a national nerve
with talk radio and TV bulletins
devoting hours of coverage the
difference may be missed with domos
celebrity this is a very high-profile
musician in South Africa extremely
popular among South Africans and someone
very much in the public eye as is her
partner who is accused of assaulting her
and in a way it's it's become highly
symbolic of a battle many women are
fighting on a daily basis it's violence
the statistics are shocking as dense
that one in four women in South Africa
have been raped many South Africans have
expressed their support for babe's
Perdomo including fans and members of
the music industry but vast swathe
disagree in fact they seem to blame her
for the
you know how oles I attend they talk a
lot and then they make for the guy to go
to that point of where the guy and that
Beatty ran out it may be repellant but
it's widely accepted musician man pizza
can do what he needs
it's not a picture of the Kenton who's
been living in all along where we've
normalized the views where it will shock
us only when we see us then we're gonna
start getting used to the impact let her
post a few more videos of him doing that
so that we can start doing that's what
they do of course that's their
relationship because that's where we end
up we are so desensitized as a country
it's upsetting it really is to me
Morocco is one of South Africa's best
loved comedians she also had to save her
sister from a partner who almost beat
her to death
come on just just as a country I think
we need to do more we all more to our
children and our women if we are going
to claim that we care that this is
happening communicating on Instagram
babes Perdomo posted a photo of her and
a friend who was killed by her partner I
could have been next it says and a small
act of defiance John sparks Sky News in
Johannesburg